yeah as for the king of jury and you got
the king turn lights on let's get
started come skate with me
ice pick one you watch a DQ on the rocks
I got so much I got more than this bros
just just some of it including
everything how much do we not get your
honor
I love jury man she's a great feeling
that my jury I was like - Stan - I think
at one point in my career I was a good
pick fine jury yeah my period I have on
now might be worth like half of me a lot
of easy words like 300 400 500 600
thousand no play no game yeah and
something good I had a reign to have my
initial on it which was a tea and I
actually used that tea ring to get me
some when I was in the seventh grade
that's how I lost my virginity
I've been infatuated with juris as a
young age I think I got my first piece I
had to be like six or seven maybe eight
my father was a con man yeah I was like
trick people I'd like money and jury and
I go to school and I'd be like the only
kid they'd have like a necklace
I've been iced out such a little boy
like for real
I've been collecting Jewish since the
early 90s it was mainly jay-z that
really inspired me I started seeing all
the diamonds on that platinum stuff he
was wearing up I gotta give me some
platinum but I got to give you a
platinum watch you know he would always
say it man you got to be wearing
platinum because weren't no silver so I
was like [ __ ] that silver [ __ ] I'm gonna
buy platinum
the plump piece The Boondocks inspired
me to get this [ __ ] so this is me we
reincarnate it and the Bulldogs pressure
this business flooded with diamond a
guppy gets in the eyes and the teeth
yellow gold rose gold yellow gold the
miners to be pinky yellows I saw it and
the rest is what yeah my necks have my
face that Cuban like ice box
the first custom piece I ever got done
was for Elliot skinnet it's my
catchphrase it's not a dictionary - you
can look it up it's getting the range on
emotion it was a 50 is from my boy
Elliot he'd do a lot of our country
pieces I got dropped off on the best so
it's Ryan drop drops are always good
talking about me drinking so I got the
letters actually drifting like these
drips coming from the bottom other
letters along higher this 60 just a
piece no Chang this right here is one of
my favorites I got this after dolsot
chat is the Tucson
rose and white cross the white diamonds
around each take it and then this is two
and a half carat which is pink stone so
I hit 220 just for this piece right here
I just got this nice long ago for ice
box just right here I'm gonna have
25,000 I want to ice it all the way out
I'll show a little Jesus piece which is
your comment go to start a kid hip-hop
few Cubans
I like Cubans because they take a lot of
space up on your neck they look really
good when you're performing on stage it
looks even cooler than when you put them
all on at the same time this trout piece
is made from a biani as well this is one
of my favorite pieces it is kind of made
like a teardrop often I get a lot of
compliments on this a lot of these
chains or either pristine or Vianney
isn't my new signature you're like shoot
your shot you know what I'm saying if I
like something I always like go up on
somebody page 10 is emoji so spend-down
oh honey
just let you know I think I'll take some
notes and then you got my earrings I
just bought some new earrings I don't
even want to speak on them they set me
back so much I don't even want to tell
you how much they cost
you wouldn't believe me I don't think
it's a good thing to tell people I don't
I just went this way just to debt away
peace the original icebox came up with
this logo they did this logo out for the
og subway son where did that that way
come from enough which way that way
that's what we thought
I got my first grill when I was 18
as you can see I'm wearing my bottom and
my top which was a gift from my boob the
honcho Ice Man
one of my favorite favorite pieces
it's my snowflake yeah from a jewelry
store all right you got me again it was
a gift I love this this is soaked made
me can't get the things this was about
$50,000 it's a self-portrait you gotta
do a split of the portions so you can
see how identical this looks this is the
Goyard logo so I wanted to do the
pattern of the Goyard you know I always
like the brand
all right go diamonds it's made out of
two chains so it's like to Franco Cuban
chains inside of the chain like I don't
know how you did it
they hit any clip these they're almost
like neutrons this is a big diamonds
he's a big like big big big big big big
big big big stars
yeah I'm trying bro mass stars is a
carrot and a half a piece this chain by
itself is 150 this piece right here
inspired by the crash better come okay
cool booth the mass and I'm a 90s baby
so I do a lot of 90s
Shapira got the e between these is the
championship true ring I have on this is
a baguette pinkie rings about don't get
me the love I know how many cares it is
this is just a regular dome ring this is
obviously my wedding ring occurred and a
half this is my wedding ring my wife met
got this one I cherish you just like the
one piece I don't care if I have on a
yellow watch or white watch the road
watch I mad at wedding rings oh it's so
pretty to them like I wanted mention
pickering getting up so I was thinking
about him like Beckett I want to get up
I want to get a pic of ring that crush
everybody and this this right this room
right here $500,000
these right here is the honcho rings cuz
I am Lord of the Rings don't nobody got
more championships than me I'm gonna go
like this I got it from like the old
like Oh dope boys from the eddies had a
there like the One Ring all four
beforehand but I wanted to move all my
fingers so that's why I got it like
individually but it turned out and
looked like the Hollywood sign that was
so cool about it so I like it
these are like a job like 60 each other
but the star is this whole is like 17
this one was like 25 just stars man guys
they don't mean [ __ ] it look like I got
this one as we kick this one were like
10 mile a string I lost was at 11 I was
like a strip club when I got home I was
[ __ ] for wearing it you ever lose any
piece of jewelry never lost any jury not
going some would somebody knock on some
wood okay and I got these I just got
these the ice box cutter runs down and
diamonds on the side on the front this
is like 18,000 subscribe it's like one
of my favorite shows
I really don't keep them all for the
rest of the video they too are I haven't
written supply I use your glasses brings
us to watch it yes sir
this is what you tell the big dope this
ap right here is varied over a million
dollars I had to get this from a dude we
had to go to auction for this in Beijing
because I really wanted it it's a big
ear ap from AP so like a lot of people
can say they got this right
I like to carry around 7 watches because
it's 7 days in a week I like to switch
them up every day Rolex bait Jase
this watch is actually gifted to me
alright first we need to give to me like
No
well actually this watch was more like
sentimental you know I'm saying so
instead of just buying a new ice and
keeping this and I just like added on in
this watch I actually paid more for this
watching you a regular pay for one
because I I built the watch right from
scratch I will watch this for more of a
fashion I work two ounces of luck and
I'm neither one of you never had the
correct time I got on to watch you guys
they're coming late this is a watch that
I wear when I'm mingling with the up
early you know me we all get to to crazy
on the army so you just drop one our
little joints you go like this and you
just mingle with them like this little
little eyes will suit I love its class
you know it's got a classy look to it
you know me know I saw a Bronx EA this
is a linguist edition mr. Richard mill
they got two strikes for Zulu Mars as a
race it's like 170 it go up in time
I bought this walk four years ago I
haven't bought another watch since this
cost me 120,000 I got this week before I
came out and I busted all the way down
I go all the way and I haven't found a
watch better than his watch right Perry
like a yacht - I try getting like a
piece from protects and all the
skeletor's and they just don't feel
right like I'm just such a big
[ __ ] guy like this the only
watched I feel normal
I'm on Wild Wild West gun I just bought
this it's all gold YTV these white
canary diamonds this is heavy as [ __ ]
it's extremely heavy this is solid all a
through like [ __ ] throw this has
money it's stopped a villain I got this
envisions to watch goggles I brought a
goggles back in China for hit I broke
these you know I said I'm sorry GQ you
broke my yeah it is the coolest piece of
jewelry in the whole rap game period I
got a autumn or and I got a um yeah
master Rollie and I just combined and I
was like some kind was up on my head a
headband you know stop gonna party my
head is lit up a hundred thousand on my
head you don't wanna be interest over
all three of us is like me trying to go
to the pieces I made this and then take
up a rocket that's what made him go get
the house so I mean he came back with
the house now we gotta go his life okay
Tommy to the vendors to bando emoji that
was our first song that was like they
got us notice from cucina and said
tokens and like an Ellen was the first
song so it was like a home base and it's
a home so I'm for 5:30 where we were
standing on an offside that's what we
came from the basement and kabum
occurred then you open the door is this
the man who welcomes you to the trap and
that's a guy when he's holding a
chocolate you got a stove in there
rose-gold pie you got a money bag
this was 250 for quarter it's heavy too
he's more than a few loaves it's when I
brought from Chinatown New York
Chinatown it was the biggest piece in
the window it was sitting in the window
for like years
nobody was purchasing it I assumed that
it was a drug dealers place and he got
arrested and he couldn't come back and
pay for it study the stuck in a window
it was a Libra plate I'm not a Libra I'm
a Capricorn but it was so big and it
made such an impression I had to have it
smell like a little paper so I put some
ice on it and I changed the Libra signs
of balance like a scale like balance
like relationships balance and you know
balance harmony balance stuff like that
so it's like that I don't finish I'm
still gonna put some more ice on it
later as the chips come in you know as
far as goals I'm all I like I like the
rose gold because it's new now the old
gold is still good you never mean
sometimes you could dip liqueur gold
chain and turn it rose gold you know me
or whatever a lot of these rings used to
be gold and they come from the mid 80s
early 90s and then I just dipped white
gold the only they look more expensive
but at one time they was all gold like
like this late most like white rose but
because I feel like it's just
oversaturated with your logo right now
even though I love you oh girl it was
beautiful on me I just want to be
different very much start wearing white
out there no evens I don't like black
eyes as well black I just don't want to
do what everybody else doing I'll make
you like having fun I'm and I feel like
when I go in the studio I go in there
just to talk about Bobby you know I'm
saying I'm gonna shoot the ball ain't in
here to be playing ain't anybody
depressed
so yeah I'll be talking about what I'm
doing and I'm gonna be flexing my wife's
ring that's the most that's the best
wearing those mares and making it
official luckily there
500 bands - on a pair of diamond big boy
with the pink star that pink diamonds
around it going around a chump I've seen
a lot of copycats - since we got that
right
you know Saturday the saying is this the
honcho bracelet just as there was a gift
given to me on my birthday and he said
hunch on on the piece on the luck every
song I put out comes with a chain let's
get it everything he ordered this a few
months ago when we had a single coming
out named drug addict I showed him the
wrong from Tony house that maybe we just
blew this tongue and some pills on it to
me I try to keep it as real colors of
the back for drugs so you got the double
Cup with the purple thing coming out a G
lady over here so pimento purse
stamps got to safety lock so it'll never
pop on him so you click the first lock
in see it doesn't move and then that's
the safety lock now I say you know you
got to get a new chain every album I
wear so much jury now that it's hard
taking all of it off at one time and put
it all alone so I always sleep with two
or three chains on I'm in a gym with a
couple of bracelets are sometimes it
most of time I shower I do everything in
my G yeah I just treat myself man you
know I'm I'm feeling the vibe I just
know color TV junkie like it some range
man you know you had that money you get
a cash on you want to spit it so bad
[Music]
you know you have a lot of guys in your
show so that was important for me
singing they'll come through and just
trough the drip real quick and it also
shows you that if you're an icy girl you
get a lot of icy gifts
all of them I just love what [ __ ] have a
roommate of [ __ ] diamonds I did it oh
but I'm not that's about all I could
tell you man
make sure you've got a big enough
bankroll put up before you go by and
this year